well look at look at society and you
tell me ask me right so so let's ask
let's ask the the Single Ladies what
would you prefer I would prefer someone
who's monogamous I left a situation
where I got the Bentley I had all that I
had the kids I had that that was great I
want a companion I want real love and to
me what monogamy means to me is someone
who's committed to themselves that's
like the answer is within you and to be
honest I feel like again like the sex
has been Lost in Translation and what it
means I don't care man or female it's
been lost as it's so sacred so for me I
have kind of taken those blinders off
where I'm like okay he has to be here
I'm okay with dating the trainer in
Austin Texas that's just where I'm at
like I don't need a certain thing
because I know what I'm wanting most
guys in that percentage are not gonna
give me so I would rather have a
monogamous man than someone who can do
whatever so you think the personal
trainer is going to be monogamous
they're like known for cheating no well
I mean I don't here's here's my thing
like I get it like I don't generalize
people because I'm one of the one of the
most misunderstood people online as well
and I feel like there's a lot more to me
and I don't like to just put everyone in
a box I'd like to get to know people so
no I'm not going to just say oh okay of
course he's gonna cheat on me like no
okay okay would you would you take a guy
that makes 35 000 a year and had a dad
Bob had a dad Bond I feel like for me I
would want someone who sorry go ahead
okay
um I pour into myself and I'm
accountable for my [ __ ] I'm aware of
what I got going on I'm not gonna have a
a mom bod I'm in the gym I had a baby a
year and a half ago I'm in the gym four
to five times a week so I would want
someone who can match at least the the
work ethic now when it comes to money I
know for me I want to be able to I do
not want to rely on a man I have I have
literally done that before it didn't pan
out my favor okay because what happens
is you get the rug grip from under you
and then now you [ __ ] get out [ __ ]
give me the [ __ ] keys it is it
isn't that so for me the lifestyle I
want I am responsible for so I don't
look for a man to make x amount of
dollars because anything that I want I'm
gonna get myself well because in my head
I feel like a guy is just as likely to
cheat if he's in the top 20 of like
looks
just as likely as okay you know what I'm
saying like it just doesn't let me let
me ask let me ask a quick question just
so I can clarify something because I
understand your points
you're saying you want a partner a life
partner are you sure and I'm not
accusing I'm genuinely asking are you
sure you're not confusing
the amount of time the man spends with
you with his monogamy because they're
different things because what happens a
lot of the time if a man's out here
chasing chicks he's barely home but
imagine you had a man who was home seven
nights a week he was always home I'm
talking about like an hour like during
his work lunch you don't even notice
then would you even give a [ __ ] about
monogamy if you had all of his time
effectively would you really care I
still would care because I I feel like
that's still just an hour a day and
we're not it's not really quality time I
feel I really have been in so many
different situations again the trainer
in Austin to the NBA player baby daddy
like I I have seen all of that stuff and
this is my personal experience and
perspective to where I want someone that
sees the value in the Grand Canyon I
want somebody who I understand okay so
that's a good point and that's so just
ask the first question I'm gonna ask a
second okay
the realization you've come to is an
interesting one it is something that
happens especially to to females as they
mature don't you think it's strange or
why do you think that zero women on
earth choose those kind of men who they
perhaps have slightly lower status but
are are more likely to be uh loyal to
them and be monogamous Etc in the modern
world because like I said the world's
changed why do you think zero women
choose them when they're at the peak of
their choices so when a woman is 19 and
she can go anywhere she wants every man
wants her she's can go on any y'all in
Miami she can get flown out to Dubai
when she has all the choices in the
world why is she completely uninterested
in those kind of men and then when she
gets to a certain age of maturity and
all there's a whole new generation of
girls who have all the choices then they
sit there and go you know what I deserve
the monogamy and data and they all of a
sudden want to grow up and mature why
don't why does no woman decide that when
she actually is at her most valuable I I
feel like for like I said I don't like
to speak for all women I just speak for
myself but I know for me that I was
looking for a man for a lifestyle
something that I was not able to do
individually by myself so that's why
it's like well yeah I want to be able to
do this do that I want to go for the
football player that was just on GQ and
in reality now I realize well okay
there's a lot that comes with that I can
make my own money I don't necessarily
need that type of guy for the happiness
that I'm looking for again seeing
without you in the Grand Canyon is a lot
different than like okay here's money
for this here's allowance for that and
that's enough of my time as you asking
why a man that is 20 21 23 is not a top
G like a 30 40 year old woman your age
actually dictates your sort of maturity
to a large extent well I'm arguing the
point the point I'm trying to make is
that what I actually think happens
especially in the modern world because
the modern world's all [ __ ] up and
nothing's the way it's supposed to be
the traditional life path of a female is
she's 17 she's 18 she's 19 and her value
is massively inflated and I don't blame
her of course it's massively inflated
imagine being 19 years old have achieved
exactly [ __ ] zero in your life
knowing nothing you put makeup on and
and sports stars billionaires actors the
most important famous people on the
planet the richest man on the planet are
begging for your attention the ego
you're going to develop let's all be
honest right the ego you're going to
development is gonna be mon you [ __ ]
mental I'm special I'm so gorgeous all
this [ __ ] right and then what
happens as they grow older as new
generations come along because the truth
is most women are are at their Peak
attraction let's say in their early 20s
as they grow older what they what women
become is far more fearful of
competition this is why you'll see a
woman who's a bit older and go oh you
know I already want monogamy what she's
scared of is her dude getting a 21 year
old that's what she's [ __ ] scared of
she may not know it she may not say it
but basically that's what the truth is
because she knows a 21 year old is gonna
be more desirable higher status more
fertile that's what she's scared of
she's mad when you're 30. so no but I'm
not it's not about that I'm telling you
the the shift in the female mentality
because when a female is 20 she doesn't
give a [ __ ] about any of this she
doesn't want to find the nice man now
she's trying to like you're saying
chasing a lifestyle chasing Mr
promiscuous chasing Mr famous doesn't
give a [ __ ] until she starts getting
scared oh [ __ ] oh my age begins with
three now and and then they change their
mentality changes it's a fear element
that's the reality and it's a biological
fear element I'll give you an example of
it you know what's amazing about humans
we are still very Primal if when when
men like these two and me when we walk
through the mall people just move it's
like you can sense when you can sense
when the big animals turn up right it's
something amazing about humans if you
have a very attractive 45 year old woman
she's gorgeous but a gorgeous 19 year
old walks in look at that 45 year old
woman's face she's Furious She [ __ ]
hates her she just doesn't like her for
no reason because women understand on
unfortunes unfortunately but you're
innately your age is a massive indicator
in your value in an inverse weight to
men men are more valuable as we get
older every man every woman knows that
every woman will sit here and go yeah
well I know man who's older than me of
course but if I say around I'm
misogynistic it's just a reality of the
world so so then we have to go into the
other point the point is this when you
were at your Peak value you had zero
interest in monogamy but then you find a
man who's 35 at his Peak value he's
finally struggled and worked because
when he was 19 no girl spoke to him when
he was 23 he was broke when he was 24 he
had no life experience when he was 25 he
couldn't [ __ ] when he was 20 whatever he
finally gets to the point where he's now
at his Peak value he met 35 is you when
you were 19. and then you're sitting
there saying to him no you should be
monogamous it's like well you [ __ ]
weren't you did whatever you wanted in
your Peak now I'm finally got there and
I had to work for my [ __ ] God gave you
God and L'Oreal gave you you I had to
[ __ ] struggle I had to go through
hell to get on this yaw you go on the
yaw with an Instagram DM I had to buy it
and now you're telling me I need to
[ __ ] settle down and behave and grow
up [ __ ] yeah because [ __ ] you're
assuming that the journey is a man that
starts with nothing to something because
there's a lot of men that's exactly the
Journey of every man on Earth
so there's there's specificity in that
can I just because that's not how it
should be for everybody that's not how
it is for everybody and not for every be
woman either zombie I just say can ask
Brittany something please
um you know like oh then you've learned
in the past and now you want to find
someone to settle down
with hindsight now would you reverse it
and like started young looking for
someone to settle down with looking for
those values that now you know I'm
talking that with hindsight okay well
I've I actually from 18 to 22 I was in a
relationship I've always actually been a
lover girl despite what I put out online
for you know yeah that's fine that's
even better
um I have always wanted one person and I
feel like I was so delusional in
thinking that oh I'm I'm like you said
like I have value I'm beautiful I'm this
I'm at my Peak like why wouldn't you
want to be with me so a lot going into
these relationships or just like P I'm
sorry just people my goal was always to
get commitment like I'm giving you my
time I'm pouring into because I want
commitment and the reality is I'd never
had I never really understood my value
so I was going through guys giving up
sex doing this and it didn't make sense
so I believe in like I stay on
everything I do like I I don't I don't
do apology tours it is what it is and I
think that's where I feel like when it
when they talk about women being
delusional and all these other things it
is true because what you have to
understand is that there are
repercussions to your decisions which is
fine so then you're talking about okay
well I want this type of guy I want this
that and that you're talking about me
maybe monogamy that's three to five
percent of animals are monogamous I
think that's what it is right so
the your window is really really small
for what you're looking for and even to
go on to the point where you said were
you talking about it's like a
subconscious fear I think it's like for
me I feel like if it was more of a fear
I would have just stayed in my situation
like it wouldn't have made sense like I
mean that was my first kid I thought I
waited and did it right I left because I
believe it there's something else on my
heart when it comes to love and I'm just
gonna have to trust that and if that
means being alone having a dog I have to
take that chance because the Bentley the
ring the house and still getting again
deceived right disrespected because
deceit is disrespect right so I just I
cannot settle for that I can't suck a
dick and shut up and that is where a lot
of people don't like my views and what I
represent because it is something new I
don't know how it's gonna [ __ ] end I
don't know what's going to happen would
you tell your 17 if you had to like what
would you tell your 17 year old self
knowing what you know now looking back
in year to meet yourself at 17. what
would you tell your what would you tell
yourself like lock it down and wait for
the right man don't have sex what would
you tell your 17 year old self
um
that the answers aren't outside of you
because I feel like I'd always look for
men to answer all of my questions that
I've ever had I thought when I had a man
it would completely complete me and I
feel like too
um especially with like my dad not being
in my life you look for somebody to
guide me like so that's where for me I
put too much value in
someone else having the answers for me
so that's why I'm really big on
accountability so I I would just tell
myself like to be patient to take your
time because I was always quick oh let's
try to get in a relationship like we
weren't even compatible there's a lot of
just not compatible factors so I feel
like for me it would be to slow down and
to really get to know people instead of
just blindly banking on potential that
most likely would ever be tapped into or
selling myself short because there's a
fear of well I don't know this could be
the best that I could get I might as
well just shut up shut up and suck a
dick and that's what that's what I meant
about about women nowadays because
exactly what you'd be telling your 17
year old self is what happened back in
the day so when I'm repeating these
things I'm gonna oh you're old-fashioned
but it seems like women do what they
like and then they hit a certain age and
say oh well I've got to settle but it's
not settling you're just getting
whatever you can you know or whatever
you deserve you know what because if you
think back now you'd be telling people
now rather than say the auntie's
old-fashioned or Auntie don't know what
she's talking about look what she'd be
telling her 17 year old self which ain't
nothing that I already said yeah because
let me finish let me finish because what
I've always said and you can check I'm
an older version of you
so where you've been
I've already been a comeback so that's
why I asked you what would you tell your
17 year old self because me telling you
is I'm telling my 30 year old self do
you understand where I'm coming from so
it's not that I'm old fashioned it's
just that
women hit a certain age and they realize
oh my God it wasn't that old-fashioned
you know it works because it does but
there's no point in waiting until you're
a certain age to start thinking about it
you know even if you're like you hold
your own accountability so it's like if
you meet somebody and they were like 17
18 and you saw the match in a certain
way they asked you for advice you won't
say do as I do you say this one this is
what happened to me and this is what I
thought and what I recommend you do is
blah blah blah I'm right around my own
and I ask you for your advice no I
totally get what you're saying like I
totally agree with that I I think that
no matter what you decide to do you have
to accept whatever repercussions come
behind that so any advice that I give to
anybody is do what you want but just
know there are repercussions good bad or
indifferent that are going to come
behind it so I mean and I think that's
just where I'm at I don't even think
it's like an age thing I think it's like
in reality I have I have a son and you
really start asking yourself questions
and again I hate that it took having a
child to really look into my life and
call myself out on my [ __ ] but you
got pregnant earlier if you got pregnant
at 18 19 would it I was always on birth
control I was on birth control for a
decade I got off birth control because
the person I was with when I have a baby
so so um again I thought I did it right
clearly not because I wasn't married but
um they still didn't workout because it
just wasn't my guy so that's where I
just think like even if I still would
have taken it slow there just for a lot
of people that just generally not my
person and that's okay
uh I was just speaking of speaking of
marriage um I wanted to know do you
think we're in as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible